foreign
so first step we will take all the
vegetables and some fruits out to wash
it
I have kale
um carrot and celerys and you first need
a bowl
baby can you help me
foreign
so I usually don't keep the stamp I will
either rip it off or you could cut it
off it's your choice maybe two stalks of
celery sticks one carrot
I don't like stuff in my way so I'm
gonna tie it and put it back into the
fridge
you could peel the scared skin but I
don't normally do it's gonna keep it and
then for the celery stick I just spray
again two three
okay you could cut the the kale into
half so I'm gonna rip it into half
oh my God
and then put into the blender
carrots two ribbon three
and then celery sticks
okay and then oh where's my banana if
you could take the taste just the
vegetable like kale carrots and celery
stick you can just blend it with water
we're not there yet so we have to put
the banana and some fruits in there to
cover the the vegetable taste a little
bit
so Banana I'll break into half it's
easier to blend
okay so if the avocado is ripe enough
you just cut the avocado around in half
and then for the pit you can squeeze it
out or
use the knife if you don't want your
hand to get dirty you can use a spoon
and then you just scoop up the avocado
so because we don't We're Not Gonna use
the skin right now we like a little bit
mango and our smoothie so I'm gonna get
the Frozen mango to add it into our
smoothies
we're using Vitamix you can make soup
with the spider mix and we always add
some water to the Smoothie because with
that water it will be very thick you
cannot blend it use future water
depends on how liquidy you like your
juice to be you can add the water as
your as your
preference so I'm gonna add
two and a half
then it's time to blend
okay I usually blend it for one minute
so it's nice and smooth oh I can open it
I can smell the celery stick
okay we could we will have heaven to do
the taste
oh let's see
let's see are you too far are you too
tall
stand back
it's Good Very Fresh two thumbs up high
five
so this is how you make happy smoothies
if you have any questions leave the
comment below and never will answer you
bye maybe say the first step
no that's so stupid who would always
know oh it's the first day I'm gonna
open the fridge
stop